you will not remember this
uh but uh we last spoke i'm gonna say
13 years ago for spiderwick
wow um i apologize i don't recognize you
that was the turning point you know the
positive boost that we both needed our
meeting in 2008
100 and that moves of course yes yeah
absolutely
so jumping right on in if you could
guest star on
any tv series what would your guests are
and why
oh i always i'm so bad at these
questions
i will be better at all of your
questions this is a dreadful beginning
isn't it
no i ted lasso is the one that first
came to mind
the reason why i'm bad at them is i feel
like i say that and then that's my like
favorite show
ever and it's the only thing i ever
watch but it has been really it has been
really good
uh and it was perfect for this last year
and it reminds me of home and i think
jason is just brilliant in it and
so i'd i'd love to do a part on that
yeah i think ted lasso is fantastic and
it explains why it wins
a lot of awards recently yes um
what movie or movies do you think you've
seen the most
um i've been re-watching some richard
curtis movies
recently i think because i've spent a
lot of time out of the uk
recently because you know we film the
good doctor here in vancouver
um i'm just always looking for you know
something that has a little bit of that
reminder of home and so those richard
curtis kind of early romantic comedies
have been
have been something i've been going back
to re-watch not to try and interject
myself into this but i got to interview
with him
for that yesterday movie and uh i was
so over the moon to talk to him just
because i'm such a fan
yeah no the writing and it and it holds
up um i mean it holds up remarkably well
too
a hundred percent uh what costumes or
props do you think you've borrowed from
set
because i know you would have never
stolen anything
um definitely have some things somehow
that ended up staying with me from bates
motel um i've got norman's manager badge
which it's not a secret like people know
that i have these things i think after
five years on a tv show they were like
fine you can take the manager's badge if
you really want it
um so i've got a couple of a couple of
things from that show
uh do you think you post too much on
social media
i don't i don't post anything so
hopefully that's not too
much i was just teasing because you
don't post on social media
i think there's one up that's got a blue
tick so people know that
the people who pretend to be me aren't
me but there's nothing i don't even have
the password for it so i wouldn't know
how to log on and post
anything but got it but it just means
that then people don't
assume that i um i don't know have said
something that i actually haven't said
you have been acting for a very long
time since you for a very long time
when did you realize that you wanted to
act
i always enjoyed it as a kid i guess i
guess as an adult that decision came for
me after
um with you know going off to
university i took two years away at sort
of 18 to 20 and then bates motel kind of
brought me back into
acting um but
so yeah that was kind of the moment
where i thought oh this is something i
want to do as an adult and making it
this sort of active decision to do so
as opposed to i didn't want it to be
something i just ended up falling into
having not
really made that choice you basically
successfully made the transition
from being like a child actor or a young
actor
to being an adult successful actor is
there someone that you credit for
helping you with this transition
i mean i feel like you've set me up for
the perfect answer to this question
stephen which is of course to say
yourself given that we apparently spoke
in 2008 and had a wonderful conversation
and each of us have been lucky since so
i mean aside from you and that kind of
real
pivotal moment in my life um probably my
my parents my family yeah my my brother
and my parents
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with more you're
you're very close you're a very close
fourth after the three of them i guess
i'll take it i say thank you um
uh you worked with uh johnny depp and
tim burton when you were younger on
charlie in the chocolate factory
when you think back on that is there
anything that you like vividly remember
from the making of that movie
the sets were just incredible um
it's still it's still hard to like wrap
one's head around what they were
what we were able to build and what was
genuinely there rather than just
visual effects they had the you know
huge
chocolate room with the chocolate river
it wasn't real chocolate but you know
with a boat that actually would go down
it and the chocolate
waterfall thing that was at the end and
it was it was genuinely like stepping
into this magical world that they
managed to
to create um and i think being able to
do that
in reality as opposed to having it as a
visual effect
was was kind of insane um and amazing to
be a part of
yeah uh yeah exactly i
really enjoy tour the pharmacy um the
andes amber yes
and that was fun thank you i'm a big fan
of that i think
i'm a big fan what was it like being a
part of that and
is one of those things where you just
thoroughly enjoyed your time oh yeah i
mean andy is obviously brilliant andy
sandberg and
just getting to team up with him and
have this this quirky love affair i
guess as we rode off
on our bikes was um was was a dream come
true
no it was great fun to do to do
something that was just entirely
different
and uh and stupidly funny in the very
best way
um and and it was yeah it was it was a
great
it was such a lovely group and everyone
was just up for trying new things and
doing silly stuff and yeah yeah for
people that are watching this interview
that have not seen it
um make an effort it's very funny and
it's only it's like 40 45 minutes
it's nothing yeah you know um so jumping
into why i get to talk to you today for
the vault
uh i watched it last night it's a super
fun popcorn movie
um and one of the things that i i
appreciated about the film
is that the person who runs the bank is
actually
smart like it's not one of these
bumbling people that you know like he is
legitimately you know he is he's just a
smartly written character
can you sort of talk about that aspect
of the script
yeah um well thank you um yeah i think
i don't know i think we're in a time
where if
you need people to be smart i think i
think most people
are smart and people end up making silly
decisions or making the wrong decisions
but not because they're
in in somehow you know considered stupid
or they don't have the
the intelligence um and so i think
part of what's fun about this is that it
is a real you know back
of several people's wits putting them
against each other from my character's
perspective who's kind of fresh out of
university and
you know imbued with this sense of like
i can do it all and i've got i'm really
clever when he's just
actually a kind of kid as well and then
coupled with someone you know at the
head of the bank as you say who's like
who who is smart and who isn't an idiot
and it makes it all the more challenging
for us
as we try and as we try and rob the bank
um
but yeah as you say it's like a great
fun um
you know bank heist movie with some with
some great
you know beautiful action sequences and
jumping in the water and getting on
ladders and
climbing buildings and uh it was very
different to something i'd done before
and so it was it was exciting to be a
part of it
well i think a lot of people don't
realize you know obviously you your year
is sort of set you're very busy with
your television series
so what was it about this script and
this project that said i want to make
this during my hiatus
um i guess it it i mean it felt
different
i was excited to play this different you
know new character
and getting to film in madrid and and do
a film that was european was also an
appeal i did languages at university i
studied spanish
um and so i went to madrid and was there
for sort of three
for in my third year i was there for
eight months living in madrid
so in some ways it was a little bit of a
return to home
uh or to the home that i'd once had as
well getting to make this
getting to make this film with some
really exceptional
uh you know spanish producers and and a
brilliant director and also some of
spain's best actors
did you find yourself you mentioned you
i lived there for eight months
did you find yourself when you went back
going back to some of the same haunts
you used to go to like whatever coffee
shop
or things that you used to do just to be
like how has it changed
a little bit and the most bizarre thing
was like because we
the city of madrid were very generous as
we were
trying to film in some of their biggest
you know
locations and squares and we were able
to shut those down and
shoot these incredible crowd sequences
which was a very different experience to
when i was there as a student
and so it was kind of bizarre to like
you know stand in the
in the middle of this square that i'd
only really seen as a tourist and like
from a distance
amongst you know just one of many other
people and then all of a sudden to be
there filming something
uh with it shut down with people
watching us filming was
was kind of was weird i can't imagine um
also it has to be weird for you because
of the success you've had
on television um uh being in madrid i'm
sure you're
you know back when you were a student no
one knew who the hell you were and now
i'm sure
you know people have you know it has to
be weird being in another city like that
and people
recognizing you yes yeah a little bit
and especially when you
especially yeah i guess just because my
experience there was so very different
to the to the experience of going back
and
and i was in a different place in my
life um
in the movie you have to do some stuff
that i could never do
from crawling across a ladder you know
like over this
huge drop uh you know using a rope
between buildings like there's no
[ __ ] way i could do some of those
things and i know it's movie magic
but can you do could you think you could
do these things in real life
or there is a zero percent chance
i mean i like to think i could i think
that's part of the fun of this film too
is that he's he's not meant to be your
you know stereotypical kind of action
hero
who gets it all right and who knows
exactly what he's doing
um he's this young guy who is
you know impulsive and when the
pressure's on he's still having fun
um and feels like he's at that point in
his life when he has nothing to lose
which makes him do kind of crazy things
but he's not meant to be this
he's but he's by no means experienced
he's by no means the best
at getting on a ladder or climbing a
wall and hopefully some of the
some of the fun of this film is you know
people seeing this guy who is just
a relatively normal guy getting swept up
in something that's much bigger than he
is uh you can be honest now and say
you did the movie just because you
wanted to talk to liam about game of
thrones
for like a month straight
liam is brilliant i had such fun with
him and he's so
he's terrific in this film too as the
kind of the the driving force really of
the
uh of you know the heist itself um
and the person who's the ring leader of
everything he's perfectly cast in it and
is just
and wonderful to work with yeah yeah and
also you know you wanted to geek out
about gaming
and he was in game of thrones yeah just
you know throw it out there
um when you think back on the making of
the film though is there like a day or
two that you'll always remember
um i think probably one of them will
just be that moment of
uh we kind of use i guess for people who
haven't seen it we use the
the sort of world cup that goes on um
during the day that we're gonna rob the
bank as the
perfect distraction in order to pull
this off and so just being there with
in for that final big sequence was very
memorable running through the crowds and
and i remember watching and having been
in spain
when spain won the world cup and so that
was another kind of
back to you know the sort of trip
into nostalgia for me and into the
memory bank
um and then i think aside from that the
the vault is
uh is protected by this intricate water
system
um to tease it in that way i guess and
so getting to do sequences
ultimately in the water in this water
tank that we're all done
very very much for real uh with some of
the
the kind of best people in the business
are doing that who had done
um you know many wonderful things before
so
so that was also brilliant yeah this is
stuff i could also never do
before no we never yeah
we we survived we survived okay but
there's this a
surprising amount of water pressure was
like thrown at us
for us to which is good you know you
always want to be
fighting against something but it was it
it was a little bit more real than
perhaps i had originally realized it was
going to be
yeah the fear on your face is not acting
exactly um uh so jumping into something
else um
one of the things a lot of actors are
lucky to get
one successful television series that
lasts more than one season
and you've been fortunate you know bates
motel was very successful
now you're on another very successful
series um have you thought about playing
the lottery
that's a good point i feel like i
although in some ways i feel like i've
won it several times already that
maybe my you know surely my luck is
gonna have to run out at some point but
um
but yeah i i feel very fortunate
especially
just the timing was it felt at the time
and still does too good to be true to
finish bates motel and then
a couple of months later be you know
filming something else and it was three
days between finishing
latest motel and the good doctor coming
along um and having to make that
decision
so it it it doesn't quite seem real that
it's that it's happened i guess
i believe daniel day kim was very
instrumental in getting the good doctor
uh made in america um have you do you
send him like birthday cards or birthday
presents
uh every year for helping you know to
get this show on the air and giving you
such a great role
or i mean what do you do to thank him
well i i
i was wondering what the all was going
to be or do you just ignore him
no um he's wonderful and he got it it
was great fun in season two because he
got to come in at the end and play
this part of um of a doctor on the show
for four episodes this sort of brilliant
arc at the end of the season and so
um of course we're you know we will
always be grateful to him for
for finding the show and wanting to
develop it in the us from the very
beginning
um and also just you know it was it was
wonderful to get to work with him as an
actor
well something that i think a lot of
people don't know about the making of tv
like i'm sure there's a lot of people
that watch the series
and don't really understand what goes on
behind the scenes the long
hours what it's like to really learn all
the dialogue
um for you i'm just curious has it
gotten any easier
to learn the dialogue that you have to
deliver each day
or is it sort of like you know it's
rinse and repeat like i get home at
night
and i gotta spend an hour or two trying
to learn
it takes me a while a surprising amount
of time
um to learn the lines
and get them into my head also sean
speaks quite quickly and has quite a
good control of his medical jargon and
i'm not
in any way medically adept and so that
takes a bit of
extra effort too um sometimes
sometimes now in season four there are
words that you
have used many times and so they become
they sort of come more naturally to you
and they roll off the tongue a little
bit quicker but then also that can be
confusing at times because we'll be
ordering
you know tests like a ct eeg and
something else
and then in one episode you'll order
that and then the other episode you'll
order
something very similar but with a slight
tweak and i find myself reverting to the
one from the previous episode instead of
the correct
uh tests for the current episode that
we're on so
in some ways learning stuff well is a
blessing and and sometimes a curse
uh where are you in this in the filming
process
uh of this season we're about three
quarters of the way through now
season four so a couple more months to
go in vancouver yeah
have you thought about what you want to
do in your upcoming hiatus are you just
being like i am taking a break
uh it'll be nice to get back home to the
uk um
and then and then hopefully we'll have
another
you know usually by now we would have
finished the season and say the break
would have been a little bit longer and
if we're lucky to get another season of
the show and and come back again
then the break will probably be a bit
shorter this year
yeah i was wondering about that because
uh generally people start filming in
july or august and
that's going to be near where you
normally i guess where you might be
rapping
so i mean could it mean that you're
going to have like two weeks off
i don't know i'm i mean
maybe the good thing
at least is that um i mean it's it it's
a lot dependent on the writing too
and you know david shaw our wonderful
main writer and showrunner
has to have some time at least to finish
one season
and wrap his head around what he wants
to do with our with our potential fifth
season so
um i i think that'll be a little break
of of some
kind yeah i've spoken to a lot of
writers and show runners and they all
talk about how
when the season begins they'll often
have you know they'll have the arc of
the season
and maybe four or five scripts done in
outlines of others
you know you've got to get ahead because
you can't just keep writing
week in and week out without being like
a head just the way the production works
yeah there's exactly the sort of bigger
pieces are always hopefully in place at
the start of the season but
but when you film over this course of
sort of eight nine months and there's a
couple of months off it's impossible to
write a whole season
in the break that you would have so
there's a requirement to kind of
just keep writing as the show goes on
uh if i'm not mistaken you did a series
called leonardo
or am i wrong about this no this is this
is correct
just making sure so i obviously haven't
seen it yet um what can you tease about
that project
uh yeah so it's about it's about the
life of leonardo da vinci i guess it's
about
you know the um
[Music]
stripping back this enigmatic facade um
and looking to try and you know discover
who the man actually was and i think
our present-day understanding of him or
is
is in some ways non-existent i think
when you think of leonardo da vinci you
don't think of an image of him you think
of mona lisa we think of the last supper
and
this series sort of follows him as he
builds these famous paintings
um but at the same time you know
stripping
stripping back who he was to reveal this
outsider
uh you know an illegitimate child a gay
man who's
struggling in many ways in his in his
life and hopefully that gives us a
little bit more of an understanding
about his art too
and allows us to appreciate it in a new
way
and that's a project it's the first one
that i've been producing through my
production company um and so it's
exciting in that way and
i get to play a small part in the in in
the show as well
i i'm obviously like everyone else
fascinated by his paintings his drawings
everything about that you know that
man's life is fascinating
what did you take away what flex
was there anything that surprised you
about his life or anything you learned
about him that you were like my god this
has to be in the series
i mean i think one of the things that
stood out and i hadn't really thought
about it in this way before
the show was that he was equally adept
in you know the arts and the sciences
and
was you know i think there's there's
many anecdotes that
that that we know about him but one of
them is you know he had these early
designs for
helicopters and didn't have the some of
the science to be able to pull it off
but knew that that's
a way that you could get something up in
the air um and i think in today's
world for whatever reason we've come to
think that
arts and science have to be you know on
the opposite sides of a spectrum and
that you have to choose one on the other
and even from school or going off to
university you have to kind of pursue
one or the other
and i think it's fascinating to look at
someone who shows that you can do both
and that you don't have to necessarily
feel
forced down one of those paths or the
other
and that there are similarities there
too it's not uh
science isn't you know all
dry and sort of
mechanical and clear-cut and aunt isn't
always
the most you know always have to be
flowery and
and and wishy-washy
uh how many episodes is it it's eight
episodes so it's an eight-part
mini-series and they didn't play
aidan turner plays leonardo and he's
pretty internet
i mean he's an okay actor come on um
is it one of these things though when
you're developing things nowadays
is everyone asking you about you know
i'm not sure if this is a limited series
or a series
how much are when you're developing is
everyone sort of saying well
can you do a multiple seasons on this or
you know what i mean like
what is it like behind the scenes yeah i
think there is um
i think there's a desire i think the
preferable thing is to have a show
that that could return and could come
back um
but and and this does have that
potential hopefully
um it's it's literally just come out in
italy which is the first place that it's
launched and has done
really well so everyone's optimistic
that there might be
there might be more we can explore in uh
in leonardo da vinci's world
you mentioned this is the first thing
you you put out through your production
company
what is it like trying to develop things
while also working full-time
the way you work i would imagine it can
be a struggle
it's exciting too though it feels like
making the most of this
opportunity um it's not just me uh the
head of development at the company
claire
londy is is wonderful uh and so i'm very
lucky to be able to
to work with her and collaborate with
her in terms of
finding new projects and and developing
things
um and the majority of our focus you
know until now has definitely been on
the tv side and our deal with sony is
for that
um but we're you know we'd also love to
to do
films and um yeah and do features
further down the line
when you are acting on set how much are
you
looking at the lens and what the dp is
doing
because down the road you want to direct
more and how much are you sort of like i
can only focus on
the acting at this moment i can't be
worried about the framing if you will
i think i've always had a natural
curiosity to that
on in terms of being aware of that side
of things um
and i and i also think that i mean every
actor is different but
i've always found there is a
collaboration that you're
always undertaking with the with the
camera um and with other members of the
crew whenever you're filming you're not
really even though we would like to
pretend and
you want to pretend that you're just
having this scene with one other person
or however many people are in the room
the reality is very different
and i think i i've always found it
exciting to know where the camera is and
what the camera
movement is trying to do and feel like
that can then help inform the decisions
that i make as well as
as an actor uh but as you say i'd i'd
love to
i'd love to direct more and um i've been
lucky to direct several episodes on the
show and direct on
on bates motel as well and uh i'd love
to continue to explore that side of
things
my last thing for you um and i thank you
for giving me so much time
when you are stepping in to direct on an
episode of the good doctor
when you were doing bass motel obviously
there's a format to these shows
but i'm sure that you also want to put
your own spin on it so how much are you
thinking
can i get like a runner that's gonna be
like
like how much are you thinking about
trying to add like a
camera movement that maybe hasn't been
done before and how much do you sort of
have to fit into the format
that has come you know that has been
established
i mean you're definitely you're
definitely fitting into
you know a style of the show that has
been established before um
i don't really approach it in terms of
thinking can i get this cool shot in
for the sake of it i think i look at the
script and then of course think are
there ways that we can help tell the
story
through you know tell the story visually
and i think there's always ways to do
that i think even on a
you know a medical procedural like ours
um
there are ways that you can help tell
the story by
through camera movement and through
moments of silence rather than just
feeling that there's a necessity to get
you know everyone's close up and then
move on
on that note i have to hit stop i'm just
gonna say um
really great talking with you again
lovely to chat with you too
i was gonna say and thank you for giving
me all the credit on your career
i really appreciate it of course i wish
you nothing but the best and thank you
so much and i really had a fun time
watching the movie
thank you and hopefully we'll chat again
before however many years it's been 13
years
hopefully we'll we'll chat sooner than
that